his is super funny, I told you guys on yesterday's
show that Donald Trump's impeachment lawyers
just quit on him and Donald Trump yesterday
was able to get new impeachment lawyers, at
least one, a guy named David Schoen.
And he went on Fox News last night with Sean
Hannity and he just imploded, showing us instantly
what this impeachment trial is going to be
like.
Here is Donald Trump's new impeachment lawyer.
Again, a bunch of his lawyers quit.
He got a new guy telling Sean Hannity that
he might call Democratic senators or as he
calls them, Democrat senators as witnesses
over what he calls bias.
What?
Yeah, I don't know either.
Let's take a look at of the capital so your
voices can get heard and they take you.
Right.
But, yeah, there are two points about this.
I would say you also should be able to call
then many of the senators as witnesses because
of the awful bias and prejudgment they've
shown.
Can you imagine any American citizen considering
it to be a trial in which the judge and jury
has already announced publicly that the defendant
must be convicted in this case?
And, in fact, Senator Leahy called demanded
that Senator McConnell vote for conviction.
Also, you know, both sides, everyone, it's
clear to them Donald Trump undercut, undercut
democracy.
How can we possibly have a fair trial?
Chuck Schumer, Senator Schumer promised a
fair and full trial.
You can't when you know that the juror and
the judge are biased going in.
Notice at the start that Sean Hannity is actually
defending Trump's role in inciting the insurrection,
saying, listen, he was telling people to go
to the capital to have their voices heard.
And it's funny to say Democratic senators
are doing something wrong by calling for conviction
before the trial.
Remember Trump's first impeachment when Republican
senators prejudged an acquittal of Donald
Trump?
Where was this guy then?
Where was Sean Hannity then saying, you know,
the trial hasn't happened yet, so they really
shouldn't be prejudging it.
They're not going to be calling any Democratic
senators as witnesses anyway.
By the way, then Trump's impeachment lawyer
says he doesn't want any videos of the insurrection
shown at the trial.
He says this has nothing to do with Donald
Trump in.
The second thing is, does this country really
need to see videotapes?
We know now, apparently, that Mr. Swalwell
and the other managers tend to show videotapes
of the riots and people calling in, people
being hurt, police officers talking.
Why does the country need that now?
We would stipulate that there was a riot that
went on that day.
It was a tragedy.
President Trump has condemned violence at
all times.
Read the words of his speech, calls for peacefulness.
This had nothing to do with President Trump.
And the country doesn't need to just watch
videos of riots and unrest.
We need to heal now.
We need to move forward.
Is that the speech Trump gave when the riot
was already over, that David Schoen is referring
to, or then the one that he gave days later
where he retroactively condemned the violence
that he was gleefully loving based on reports
from the actual day of January 6th.
It's funny how David shewn keeps saying the
country doesn't need to see videos of the
Trump riot.
The trial is for senators.
Now, I understand it's nationally televised.
I know the country will see whatever evidence
is put forward, but the trial is for the senators
to adjudicate.
What justification is there for not including
relevant video evidence during the trial for
the people who are going to be adjudicating
guilt or innocence or guilt or lack of guilt
to make it easier for them to acquit?
Maybe he doesn't want the videos put up there.
Oh, I don't know that that footage was never
presented.
And you'll remember that Kelly Lefler hilariously
said at one point during her senatorial campaign
when asked about the Trump grab them by the
You-Know-What tape.
Oh, I don't know what tape is that.
I don't know the reason you put the footage
in front of in front of the senators during
the trial is so nobody can say, listen, I
don't know, based on what I saw during the
trial, which is all we're supposed to consider,
I didn't see any reason to convict Donald
Trump.
Now, the Republicans aren't going to convict
him anyway, but at least expose them for the
shills that they are by putting all of the
evidence in front of them, including video
of the riot.
Now, one last clip.
Here's a possible preview of the defense strategy,
which is to call the entire thing unconstitutional.
Then you've hit many of the main arguments
that I think are attractive.
The American people, they're all right on.
But I'm going to say to you that besides the
fact that this process is completely unconstitutional
and that this is a very, very dangerous road
to take with respect to the First Amendment
putting at risk any passionate political speaker,
which is really against everything we believe
in in this country, the foundation of the
first.
Amendment, but I'm going to tell you, I think
it's also the most ill-advised legislative
action that I've seen in my lifetime, it is
tearing the country apart at a time when we
don't need anything like that.
I think President Biden missed a great opportunity
to be a statesman and demanded that this thing
be called off.
Frankly, this is the political weaponization
of the impeachment process.
There was a rush to judgment.
Listen, when President Trump became president
the day he was elected, there were calls for
his impeachment ready.
This is the weapon they've tried to use against
him.
But now we know also that the agenda Mrs.
Pelosi and others is simply to bar President
Trump from ever running for president again.
And that's about as undemocratic as you can
get.
Can you imagine the slap in the face, that
is, to the 75 million or more voters who voted
for Donald Trump?
So this is not a First Amendment issue.
Donald Trump is president, had the biggest
bully pulpit in the world.
He used it and that bully pulpit caused a
riot.
Now, there are possible consequences for that
speech.
There won't be because Trump will be acquitted.
But these are the possible consequences.
To your speech, David Schoen calling for Joe
Biden to demand the trial be called off, by
the way, is ridiculous.
As I've said for weeks and months now, Joe
Biden should have no involvement whatsoever
in the impeachment trial.
Trump was impeached by the House before Joe
Biden was even president.
Biden should do nothing one way or the other,
period.
And then David shown even sort of placates.
I don't know if you noticed this.
He placates the stop the steel conspiracists.
He says the 75 million or more voters who
voted for Trump, that's a dog whistle.
That's the suggestion that 75 million people
officially voted for Trump.
But there may even be more uncounted votes
out there that we still need to respect as
well.
This guy is absolutely pathetic here.
He's merely a political hatchet man, a political
tool he should be ashamed of, of himself.
And the trial starts one week from today and
we will be covering much
of it.